then murdered hundreds of American
civilians and service the recent attacks
on US targets in Iraq including rocket
strikes that killed an American and
injured four American servicemen very
badly as well as a violent assault on
our embassy in Baghdad were carried out
at the direction of Solomon Solomon he
made the death of innocent people his
sick passion contributing to terrorist
plots as far away as New Delhi in London
today we remember and honor the victims
of salome knees many atrocities that we
take comfort in knowing that his reign
of terror is over
salamati has been perpetrating acts of
terror to destabilize the Middle East
for the last 20 years what the United
States did yesterday should have been
done long ago a lot of lives would have
been saved
just recently solemn and he led the
brutal repression of protesters in Iran
were more than a thousand innocent
civilians were tortured and killed by
their own government we took action last
night to stop a war we did not take
action to start a war I have deep
respect for the Iranian people they are
a remarkable people with an incredible
heritage and unlimited potential we do
not seek regime change however the
Iranian regime's aggression and the
region including the use of proxy
fighters to destabilize its neighbors
must end in a must and now the future
belongs to the people of Iran those who
seek peaceful coexistence and
cooperation not the terrorist warlords
who plunder their nation to finance
bloodshed abroad the United States has
the best military by far anywhere in the
world we have the best intelligence in
the world if Americans anywhere
threatened we have all of those targets
already fully identified and I am ready
and prepared to take whatever action is
necessary and that in particular refers
to Iran under my leadership we have
destroyed the ISIS territorial Caliphate
and recently American special operations
forces killed the terrorist leader known
as al Baghdady
the world is a safer place without these
monsters America will always pursue the
interests good people great people great
souls while seeking peace harmony and
fragility with all of the nations of the
world thank you god bless you god bless
our great military and God bless the
United States of America thank you very
much